[موسيقى]
طاب مساؤكم قبل ثلاث سنوات زار الحبر
الاعظم الامارات العربيه المتحده ووقع مع
شيخ الازهر
احمد الطيب وثيقه الاخوه الانسانيه هذا
تقارب بين قطبين من العالم المسيحي
والاسلامي يهدف الى ترسيخ ثقافه التسامح
اليوم المسار يستمر في بلد خليجي اخر هو
البحرين ماذا تحقق خلال ثلاث سنوات وما
مستقبل هذا الحوار يسعدني استقبال ضيوف
عبر عبر عبر الاقمار الصناعيه وعبر
التواصل بالانترنت ابدا بالكاتب السياسي
الاستاذ عبد الله الجنيد من المنامه سيكون
كذلك معي من روما مندوب الوكاله الوطنيه
للاعلام لدى الكرسي الرسولي الاستاذ طلال
خريص وسيكون معي كذلك من القاهره الدكتور
عبد الباسط السلامه
باحث متخصص في تحليل بنيه الخطاب الديني
استاذ بجامعه الازهر ومعي من بيروت كذلك
الدكتور سليم الطاهر عميد مؤسس لكليه
الحقوق والعلوم السياسيه في جامعه فينيسيا
في لبنان البدايه من المنامه معك الاستاذ
عبد الله الجنيد سؤال بسيط لماذا البحرين
والامارات المنطقه
[موسيقى]
تعدد الحويات
فبالتالي يجب ان تكون فقط
لانها نموذج
الاستاذ سليم الظاهر
انت من الاوائل الذين دافعوا عن فكره
الاخوه الانسانيه اشرح لنا هذا المفهوم
يسعدني ويشرفني ان اتناول هذا الموضوع
انما
يقتضين الواجب واجب الوفاء ان انوها بدور
القناه قناه فرنسا
اذ كانت
قد وجهت الي دعوه كريمه في
8/7/2018
للحديث عن الاخوه عن عن قضايا الحوار
وعن حقوق الانسان في المسيحيه والاسلام
يومها تناولت وباختصار قضيه الاخوه
الانسانيه في تعليم الدينتين المسيحيه
والاسلام وانا اتكلم عن مواقف كل من قداسه
البابا
وفضيله الامام الاكبر الدكتور احمد الطيب
كانت القناه تبص صورا لي لقاءات لهما هذا
هذا العمل الجميل هذا العمل البروفيسيونال
المهني جدير بالتنوين ويومها في
8/7/2018
كان ذلك اول اطلاله علنيه
للكلام عبر الاعلام عن قضيه الاخوه
الانسانيه مع انني كنت قد ابتدات بتدريسها
قبل سنوات في العام 1995
نعم
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه
لقضيه الاخوه
الانسانيه يتساءل المرء
وبختصار ماذا يعني ان ينظر الانسان الى
الانسان الاخر على انه اخوه
طبعا يحافظ على حياته يحافظ على حقوقه
يحافظ على املاكه يحافظ على عائلته
يحترم ارائه
يتشاور معه لا يفرض عليه شيئا
ولا يهيمن ولا يهيمن عليه انما يتشاور معه
طالما هو اخوه باختصار كلي طبعا يلزمنا
همم ساعات للحديث عن همم التفاصيل في
مفهوم الاخوه الانسانيه الى القاهره الان
همم معك دكتور عبد الباسط السلامه هيكل
همم
همم الان يمثل العالم الاسلامي في هذا
التقارب همم مع العالم المسيحي يمثله
دكتور احمد
الطيب همم ما رمزيه هذه المشاركه
همم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحياتي لكم
ولكل المشاهدين
فضيله الامام الاكبر شيخ الازهر له موقف
واضح همم ولا يختلف ولا يقل عن موقف
قضاياسه البابا في ان كليهما يقود مؤسسات
ذات ثقل عالمي وقادره على احداث حاله من
القبول لخطاب التعايش وتقديم القيم القيم
المواثيق الحقوقيه العالميه التي هي بعيده
عن الشارع المصري والذي كان في حاله
اختطاف وابتعاد عن مفردات همم التي
تتبناها المؤسسه الازهريه لصالح جماعه
التميز بالاسلام على المسلمين ففضيله
الامام الاكبر من خلال هذه السنوات
الماضيه هوسخ ويعمل ساحيا دائما على همم
اشاعه ونشر مفاهيم جديده هذه تؤكد على انه
لابد من العمل المشترك لمواجهه التحديات
التي تواجه الانسان بشكل عام من التغير
المناخي من معدلات الفقر المرتفعه في
العالم وانه لا يمكن ان يكون الصراع هو
الحل بل لابد من بناء خطاب دعايشه تسامحي
يقوم على التبادل الاحترام مع الاعتراض
بانه لابد ان يوجد مساحات من الخصوصيه في
كل تجربه دينيه ولكن يوجد مشترك يمكن
البناء عليه فيما بينهم واظن ان الدكتور
همم فضيله الامام له دور بارز بحضوره
الشعبي في الشارع المصري وما يحظى به من
قبول في المجتمع الدولي في دعم هذا الخطاب
طيب الى روما الان مع ضيفنا الرابع
الاستاذ طلال همم
انت تعرف انت تتابع منذ سنوات طويله اخبار
الفاتيكان هل والحديث اليوم عن عهد جديد
في التواصل مع مع الاديان الاخرى وعلى درب
هذه الاخوه الانسانيه
صفحه جديده في
حياه الفاتيكان يعني كانت هناك كانت هناك
اهتمام كبير عندما كانت الشيوعيه يعني كان
هناك صراع بين الشيوعيه والراسماليه
ويعني عندما بعد سقوط حائط برلين
بابا بيقول الثاني هو اللي بدا هذا الطريق
ونحنه نتذكر
فقدنا الاتصال مع روما مع الاستاذ طلال
خريس
وهو وعاد الان تفضل
السودان وزهره يعني دول اسلاميه عديده
ولكن في فتره جاء فيها الباب رد سيغال وهو
الماني كان يسير بهذا الطريق ولكن ما اعطى
زخم كبير لهذا الحوار ودفع قوي هو البابا
فرنسيس لان البابا فرنسيس ادرك تماما كما
يدرك الفاتيكان كما تدرك الدبلوماسيه
الفاتيكانيه انه لها لا لا يمكن تحقيق
السلام الا على قاعده الحوار والعيش
المشترك بين الشعوب يعني نحن نتحدث اليوم
عن اصغر دوله في العالم
والاقوى دوله دبلوماسيه وهذا ما شاهدناه
منذ اسبوعين عندما زار الرئيس مكرون همم
همم قداسه البابا وطلب منهم ان همم التدخل
باكثر من ملف منها الشرق الاوسط منها
الازمه الاوكرانيه يعني بعد ما فشل فشلت
الدبلوماسيه العالميه طلب من قداسه البابا
ولكن البابا كما كما تعلمون ليس لديه جيش
فهو قوي بالحوار قوي بالتواصل قوي عبر
الكنائس يعني همم ما اريد ان اقوله بان
الفاتيكان اختار البحرين لانه البحرين هو
نموذج للتعايش هناك تسامح كبير في البحرين
همم تجاه الاقليه والفاتيكان يدرك تماما
اين يبدا واين ينتهي يعني هناك اهتمام
كبير بالبحرين وهذه الزياره جاءت بعد
الاتصالات وبعد لقاءات عديده يعني نضجت
وقام بها اليوم همم قد البابا الا اذا كنا
نريد ان نتحدث بعد ذلك ماذا انتجت هذه
السنوات يما يمكنني التطرف اذا الى ذلك
اذا اردتم سنعود الى هذا السؤال لكن دعنا
نبقى مع المنامه مع الاستاذ عبد الله
الجنيد همم
يعني هناك سبب ما يجعل الحبر الاعظم يعود
الى الخليج بعد ثلاث سنوات من من تلك
المبادره من ذلك النداء الذي اطلقه همم مع
الدكتور احمد الطيب شيخ الازهر
نعنع
الى جمله ما تتحقق مثلا
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
الان كذلك لدينا مثلا همم كرسي الملك عبد
الله خليفه
همم
هل يمكن الاناء
ماتش للتاكيد هناك برامج التسامح وزاره
التسامح في الامارات
مثلا دكتور محمد عيسى
احتضن همم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعمليه جنان الهويه الوطنيه
نعم الاستاذ عبد الله الجنيد لحظه فقط لا
اعرف ماذا تستخدم مايكروفون لان الصوت همم
ربما قد نجده سيتواصل معك الزملاء
لنجد هل لا نعود الى روما اليك الاستاذ
طلال
همم هل هذا التقارب مستمر هل حقق فعلا
النتائج من موسى
كل اسبوع يمر هناك تطور بالعلاقه بين
العالم الاسلامي وبين الفاتيكان يعني نجد
ذلك بالعدد الكبير
للممثليات الدبلوماسيه في حاضره الفاتيكان
يعني همم اليوم الفاتيكان يستضيف اكثر من
90 دوله ممثله بين همم تستضيف ايطاليا اقل
من 150 دوله منين وهذا هذا التطور كبير
اما بالنسبه للنتيجه النتيجه جيده جدا فقد
غيرت في عقليه المواطن الاوروبي ونظرته
الى الاسلام ونظرته الى العرب صحيح ان
هناك احزاب يمينيه ولكن هذه الاحزاب ليست
لم تعد كما كانت في الماضي فاشيه ومعاديه
للعرب كل ذلك يعني الكنيسه همم يعني راس
الكنيسه متشعب جدا همم يبدا براس الكنيسه
وينتهي همم بالكنيسه الصغيره ينتهي
بالجمهور يعني هناك منذ توقيع معاهده
الاخوه في الامارات العربيه تغيرت اشياء
كثيره حتى ان الصحافه اليوم الايطاليه انا
اطلع يوميا على اقوال الصحف اليوم الصحافه
الايطاليه تحمل عناوين رئيسه رئيسيه
لزياره البحرين دوله صغيره
ما اا يعني عدد قليل جدا من ال- اا
الاوروبيين يعرفها ولكن اليوم في هذه
الايام التي مرت ثلاثه ايام البحرين هي
على لسان كل مواطن ايطالي كل مواطن في
الفاتيكان هذه هي النتيجه هذا الحوار انا
او يمكنني القول بان اليوم الفاتيكان هو
اقوى دبلوماسيه في العالم لان العالم فشله
في احلال السلام لان العالم ليست لديه
اقنيه دبلوماسيه همم حقيقيه يستطيع من
خلالها دفع عمليه السنه الدول الكبرى
اليوم تعلق اعمال كبيره على قداسه البابا
وقداسه البابا همم يعني يختار الدول التي
يمكن من خلالها الانطلاق الى مرحله جديده
البحرين اليوم دوله مسلمه دوله صغيره دوله
استطاعت ان تحتضن اكثر من مليون اجنبي
وتمنحه مع الحقوق
وساعه ساهمت في بناء الكنائس والكتائب
وساهمت ايضا بالتعليم المسيحي يعني اين
يمكن ان يبدا فيبدا همم تبدا الكنيسه
الكاثوليكيه حيث يمكن ان تبدا نعم الى
القاهره همم معك دكتور عبد الباسط السلامه
هيكل همم في العالم دعوات ل- همم يعني
تسعى الى تفريق همم بني ادم عن بعضهم
البعض همم هناك مثلا همم
باسم الولاء والبراء من يقولون همم لا
تتعاملوا مع غير المسلمين همم كيف تقاوم
كيف يقاوم الازهر افكارا كهذه
الازهر منذ القدم وله محاولات كبيره في
تعزيز مفاهيم الانسانيه والدعوه الى ترسيخ
ميثاق الاخوه الانسانيه الشيخ محمد مصطفى
الميراغي عليه رحمه الله شيخ الازهر
الاسبق في عام
1939 وتحديدا في ابريل قبل الحرب العالميه
بخمسه شهور دعا العالم ودعا الاديان الى
حوار والوصول الى وثيقه تمنع الاغتسال
والحروب الازهر هو يمثل
الملاذ للعالم في مواجهه اصوات التشدد
التي تنبعث بين الحين والاخر اصوات تقول
وتريد ان تقدم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
بانه الضحوق القتال ويريدون ان يقدموا
رساله النبي الذي قدمه ربه وقال وما
ارسلناك الا رحمه للعالمين يريدون ان
يقدمونه في حاله صراع مع العالم وكانه
ليحارب العالم الازهر دائما يكشف زيف هذه
الدعوات ودائما هو في صداره المواجهه لانه
يريد ان يعزي خطابا تعايشيا خطابا سلميا
خطابا يحترم الاديان لانه لم ياتي لمحو
وللدخول مع صراعات مع هذه الاديان ولكن
الله سبحانه وتعالى كما يقول القران
الكريم في نصوصه المقدسه هو بانه جعلكم
شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا فالتنوع هو اصل في
هذا الوجود الانساني التعايش الذي يتبناه
ويحث عليه الازهر هو يقوم على ان التعايش
في معناه هو حق الحياه والعمل المشترك من
اجل ان ينهض بالانسان من مختلف الديانات
والاعراف والمختلف الخلفيات الثقافيه وهذا
لن يكون ولن يتحقق الا عندما اعترف بالاخر
اعترف بحق التنوع بحق الاختلاف وه يسعى ان
يرسيه الازهر في مناهجه وفي خطابه وهذا ما
يسعى الازهر ان يقربه الى المواطن في
الشارع لان المواطن في الشارع المصري يثق
بمرجعيه وبخطاب الازهر ولذلك العالم
والمؤسسات والدول تراهن على ان يقوم
الازهر بهذا الدور في مواجهه خطابات
التشدد التي ترى اي محاوله من محاولات
التقارب وكانها هي مؤامره على الاسلام
وكان الاسلام في حقيقته ليس دين فطره
بمعنى دين انسانيه الاسلام يقدم خطاب قيمي
انساني يستطيع ان يفهمه اي انسان لان
اللغه المشتركه التي يمكن ان يتعايش وان
يتحول من خلالها هي لغه القيم الرحمه
التسامح العدل الحريه همم فهذا ما يسعى
الازهر الى ترسيخه والعمل من اجله نعم
بيروت معك الدكتور سليم الطاهر هل حوار
الاديان اليوم ااا ناجح
نعم الحوار ناجح وطبعا ثم تتطور كبير حدث
ما بين
مرحله الستينات او ما قبل والمرحله
الحاليه
الدور الكبير الذي يلعبه او يطلع به كل من
قداسه البابا
وفضيله الامام الاكبر همم
كتب تاريخا جديدا في العلاقات ما بين
المسيحيين والمسلمين ليس فقط في الشرق
الاوسط انما على
مستوى العالم
طبعا انا اقترح ان ان يتم التركيز في
الحوار الاسلامي المسيحي على موضوع القيم
اؤكد موضوع القيم وان وان نبتعد عن موضوع
العقيده طبعا سميتا اختلافات بين تعليم
الديانتين ليس دينا واحدا هما دينين
وبالتالي سمت اختلافات وما يجمعنا بشكل
واضح هو القيم المشتركه في تعليم
الديانتين وهذا ما اشرنا اليه وما طرحناه
منذ شهر يناير
1993 في ندوه في شمال لبنان كان عنوانها
القيم المشتركه في المسيحيه والاسلام
وهذا الطرح طرح التركيز
على القيم المشتركه هو يتيح
للحوار ان يخطو خطوات كبيره وفي مقدمه
القيم المشتركه
تاتي قضيه الاخوه الانسانيه الاخوه
الانسانيه هي قيمه عالميه كبرى هي قيمه
هامه هي قيمه اولى في حياه البشريه جمعاء
وقد طبعا نثني على كل على الوثيقه على
مضمون على المبادره اولا بتوقيع الوثيقه
وثانيا على مضمون هذه الوثيقه التاريخيه
الاخوه الانسانيه
بامكانها ان تخفف ان لم تلغي التطرف
التعصب
اخذ المواقف التي تؤذي الاخر اذ
طالما ان الاديان الموحده اي الاسلام
والمسيحيه تعلم الاخوه الانسانيه لا
يستطيع اي انسان طبعا يدعي او يؤمن حقيقه
بتعليم دينه ان يرفض هذه القيمه الكبرى
هذه القيمه الانسانيه على مستوى العالم
انا اعتبر ان
الاخوه الانسانيه يمكن او
تشكل حلا
تشكلوا بدايه الحل لما يحدث من اييي لما
يقع من حوادث بين المسيحيين والمسلمين في
العالم انما طبعا وكما قال لنا لعائلتي
وانا
قداسه البابا فرنسيس عندما كان لنا شرف
اللقاء معه في واحد ايار مايو 2019 قال
لنا حرفيا
الفودي ترافاي يجب ان نبذل يجب ان نقوم
بعمل وهذا العمل هو همم الذي تقوم به
اللجنه العليا لحد الان الذي تقوم به
اللجنه العليا للاخوه الانسانيه
وبكفاءه وبي همم جداره على مستوى او في
اطار العلاقات بين
الاديان
وتحديدا بين المسيحيين همم والمسلمين
وانا اقترح في هذا الايطار اذا شئت ان ان
اقترح ان يكون لبنان نقطه الانطلاق
لترحي قضيه الاخوه الانسانيه لطرح تجسيد
الاخوه الانسانيه على ارض الواقع
طيب الاستاذ طلال طلال الاخرس همم اتفضل
ولا فيلسوف ولا كاتب كبير انا مجرد مراسل
ما اراه كل يوم اوكله الى الراي العام
يعني عندما اتيت الى ايطاليا عام
1979 كان الوضع يختلف تماما تماما عندما
كان مسلم يدخل الكنيسه
المسيحيه كان ينظرون اليه باستغراب اليوم
المسيحيين والكنائس تسع همم ذنبا الى جامع
المسلمين للحصول على كل حقوقهم الدينيه
يعني على سبيل النساء هناك من يحول
الكنيسه الى جامع ويهديه الى المسلمين
هناك من يبحث عن
يعني ارض من اراضي الكنيسه لجعلها يعني
مقبره للمسلمين يعني كتعاون حقيقي ونحن
نتحدث لا نتحدث عن نظام عربي زعيم يتكلم
وهناك عالم من الطرشان عندما يتكلم قداسه
البابا اليوم في الفاتيكان صوته يصل الى
اصغر كنيسه في ابعد مناطق العالم نحن نذكر
عندما كانت همم الدول الغربيه عام
19 2013 تريد ان تقصف دمشق قال قداسه
البابا غدا كلنا نصلي الى سوريا اكثر من
مليونين مليارين شخص بداوا يصلون الى
سوريا ممنع الغرب ضرب قصر الجمهوري في
دمشق يعني نحن نتحدث بحقيقه عن نتائج
كبيره جدا نحن نتحدث عن
اعظم وهو رجل مهم جدا صوته همم يعني همم
يصل الى كل ارجاع الارض انا اعتقد با هناك
تحسن كبير وهمم اتقدم بالشكر صراحه الى
جلاله الملك البحرين والى
السفير البحرين في روما الذين عملوا كل
الوقت لانجاح هذه الزياره وايضا وايضا الى
السفير البابوي في في منطقه الخليج يعني
هذا حدث كبير جدا ان ياتي قداسه البابا
الى البحرين بعد ما ذهب الى الايه
الامارات وهذا يقوي ايضا الحق العربي
نعم
الدكتور عبد الباسط سلامه هيكل من القاهره
راينا يعني راينا ان البابا هو يمثل
الكاثوليك في العالم
وكما سمعنا من الاستاذ طلال الخريص عندما
يقول كلمه ما لها صدن كبير
ما الذي ما الذي يسمح
للازهر ان يكون له كل هذا الاشعاع وهل هذا
الاشعاع ما حجمه هذا الاشعاع ما قوته
عندما
يدافع عن فكره
الاخوه الانسانيه
الازهر يسعى الى ان يحدث حاله من تنظيم
الخطاب الديني في ما بين السنه
وارى ان هناك التفاف وقبول
اقليمي ودولي لان يقوم الازهر بهذا الدور
ولانه كما قال فضيله الامام الاكبر في
مؤتمر الاسلام والغرب تكامل تنوع وتكامل
في عام 2015 اا قال بان الاسلام مقتطف
وتحدث بان الدين الاسلامي يتعرض لاكبر
عمليه اختطاف
وان الاسلام الذي
يتبناه الازهر ليس اسلام يدعو الى الصراع
ولا الى العنف ولا الى الاقتتال كما يروج
له او روج له من الطائف الطرح الذي تقدمه
جماعات العمل المسلح
وترحم من بعض المؤسسات الغربيه التي والان
تقدم الاسلام من خلالها
فالاظهر من خلال خطابه ومن خلال المؤسسات
الدوليه والمؤسسات الدينيه الكبرى همم مثل
الفاتيكان هو يسعى الى ان يقدم الوجه
الاخر والوجه الحقيقي للاسلام ففي عام
2014 الازهر عقد مؤتمرا تحدث فيه عن
الدوله المدنيه وما يعرب بدوله الخلافه او
اصوليه الخلافه
ليقدم طرحا جديدا ومقاربه قويه تدعو الى
مجتمعه الى دوله متنوعه تتبنى وتقوم على
حقوق المواطنه الكامله ولاول مره يتم
اقصاء مفهوم الاقلبيات نعم لا نتحدث على
اقليات داخل المجتمعات المسلمين ولكن نحن
نتحدث عن مواطنين فهذا خطاب متقدم وخطاب
اكثر
تعايشيه همم الامر الاخر في مؤتمرات
الازهر الاخيره همم فكك كل المصطلحات
والمفاهيم
لتستدعيها الجماعات مثل مفهوم دار الحرب
ودار الاسلام وقال بان مثل هذه المفاهيم
هي مفاهيم فقهيه تاريخيه اصبح لا وجود لها
لانه من الممكن الان في كل بقعه من العالم
من الممكن ان يعلن المسلم عن هويتي وان
يمارس شعارات دون اي نوع من انواع
الاضطهاد او التضييق وهذا معناه ان هذه
المفاهيم اصبح له وجود لا في العصر الحديث
كذلك مفهوم الجهاد كما جاء في ورقات
الابحاث التي قدمت في مؤتمرات الازهر
ويتحدث الان ليس عن الجهاد بمفهوم السلاح
اطلاقا هذه كلها مفاهيم تاريخيه نحن نتحدث
عن جهات العلم واستفرار الجهل لمواجهه
تحديات اكبر في هذا العالم
وهذه التحديات لا يمكن ان نتوقف امامها
ولا يمكن ان نتجاهلها لان تهدد وجود
الانسان
وتجدد وجود هذا العالم وجود هذا الكون اا
هناك من يست- يضعف من دور الاديان ومن دور
الاسلام ومن دور الازهر في احداث هذا
العراق والرد على هذا انه نحن الان لن
نستطيع ان نستعيد الشعور بالمسؤوليه جه
هذا العالم ولن نعزز من خطاب القيم
الروحيه الا بان نمنح الاسلام المعتدل
الاسلام الوسطي من خلال مؤسسته وفي مقدمه
الازهر دورا حقيقيا ليقود الخطاب القيم
الذي اؤكد عليه انه يوجد منظومه قيميه بين
مختلف الاديان نستطيع ان نبني عليها نعم
همم همم الاستاذ طلال الخليج يعود اليك في
روما عندما اصغي اليكم ضيوفي الاعزاء
جميعا همم اشعر ان العالم بخير والعالم
ليس بخير يعني همم اليس كل هذا همم يعني
كلاما مثاليا الاخوه الانسانيه المستقبل
للتقارب بين بين البشر همم قليلا من
الصراحه ما الذي تراه همم
عائقا الاستاذ طلال عائقا وبصراحه في في
وجه هذه الفكره النبيله الاخوه الانسانيه
يعني اليوم الشعوب الشعوب متقاربه عندما
تلتقي الشعوب لا يوجد اي عائق ما بينها
ولا تتحارب فيما بينها هي الانظمه الانظمه
التوسعيه هي الفكر الديكتاتوري
المصالح الماليه الكبيره هي التي
تسبب الحروب الاديان لا تسبب الحروب اريد
ان اعطي مثلا بسيطه على ذلك يعني على سبيل
المثال هناك فاتيكان بدايه استقلاليه تامه
عن العالم همم
يتراضى معه ولكن الفاتيكان ده سياسه
مستقله اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار الكنيسه
الروسيه الكنيسه الروسيه اليوم تابعه
لكوتن
وتختلف مع الفاتيكان لان بوتين يختلف مع
الفاتيكان يعني عندما يكون هناك كنيسه
مستقله
وازهر مستقل
همم يعني اديان اخرى مستقله من السهل جدا
ان نصل الى
تقارب وعايش مشترك ابدا لان بين الشعوب لا
توجد اي مشكله خذ مثلا همم لبنان لبنان
هناك 18 طائف ويعيشون سويا وليست هناك اي
مشكله المشكله هي السياسه مشكله من يريد
ان يقسم همم هؤلاء الطوائف الى الى احزاب
من يريد تجيش الطوائف يعني هذه المشكله
همم كبيره هذه المشكله لا لا ليست موجوده
في اوروبا
الكنيسه قويه جدا والديها جامعات ولديها
مدارس ولديها سفراء اقوياء التاثير على
همم على همم على همم
الكاثوليك صعب جدا من قبل سياسيين ولكن في
بلده اخرى هناك انظمه باستطاعتها
تفرق الناس
نعم قطع قطع الدكتور سليم الطاهر من بيروت
تفضل
[موسيقى]
لا اسمع لا يسمعنا على ما يبدو لا يسمع
نعود اليك دكتور عبد الباسط سلامه هيكل من
القاهره
تحدثت قبل قليل عن دور الازهر وعن هذه
يعني عن هذا البرنامج الذي يقوم به منذ
سنوات بصراحه مره اخرى هل هناك تجاوب من
العالم الاسلامي مع هذا العمل الذي يقوم
به الازهر ام هي مساله مصريه وتبقى في مصر
اريد ان اقول في هذا الامر الاثر عندما
يريد ان يحرك المياه الراقده على مستوى
الشارع المصري لا استطيع ان اقول انه نووي
يحرك هذا بشكل كامل
لان الامر ليس بالعمر ليسير وليس بالامر
الهين اذا كنا نتحدث عن عشرات السنوات من
عمل داوود لجماعات ومن بخطاب سلفي ظاهره
نصوص حرفي يمارس حاله من التحريض ويؤكد
على دائما على حاله من التميز الديني
الاستعلائي حتى على المسلم مش وليس فقط
على المختلف في الدين واا دائما يمارس
خطاب يقوم على فكره الولاء والبراء
والانتماء والتجنس بالاسلام وليس التجنس
بالارض والانتماء الى الوطن الذي يعيش الى
علي فهناك ما زلت اشكاليه في الدائره
الاولى وهي دائره الوطن المصري او الشارع
المصري فما بقى هنا اذا اردنا ان نتجاوز
ذلك
دوائر اخرى والى اماكن اخرى لا سيما ان
داخل بنيه الفكر الاسلامي والعقل المسلم
تتعدد المرجعيات يعني الامر في في الخطاب
الاسلامي السني ليس كما هو عندما نتحدث عن
الكنيسه الكاثوليكيه ذات المرجعيه الواحده
الواضحه والمحدده في الطرح السني يتنازع
على المرجعيه الدينيه اطياف متعدده ما بين
مرجعيات لجماعات وما بين الازهر كمؤسسه
وما بين مؤسسات دينيه همم قطريه في كل
قطره في كل دوله
نعم
هل يعني
انا اريد ان اعطي مثلا على ذلك لماذا لم
يذهب قداسه البابا لزياره لبنان
لانهم يدركون تماما لان هذه الزياره كل
طرف يريد ان يستغلها سياسيا ولا يرى فيها
اتفاق همم حوار مسيحي اسلامي حقيقي يرى
احزاب متناقره بينها همم تريد
تتسلح بزياره البابا لحد لما لتمرر مثلا
همم
مخططاته مثل منع القضاء من همم القيام
بواجبه بالنسبه للانفجار بيروت لا اريد
الدخول المطور ولكن البابا لا سوف لا يزور
لبنان الا اذا وجد ان هناك ارضيه مشتركه
لا تستغل ولا بالشكل من في اداه سياسيه
نعم
تعليق بين الدكتور سليم الظاهر في بيروت
نعم انا اوافق على ان سمه استغلال سياسي
كبير
لمشاعر اللبن لمشاعر اللبنانيين لمشاعر
الدينيه للبنانيين بشكل عام
السياسيون في لبنان الطبقه السياسيه في
لبنان تحاول تسعى كل جهدها لتحقيق مصالحها
ويضربون
لا يهتمون بما فيه الكفايه هذا اذا بدا
ذلك
بمصالح الناس بالخير العام
انا اوافق على التحليل الذي يقول ان
زياره قداسه البابا قد الى لبنان قد تم
ارجاؤها بسبب الظروف الداخليه وخاصه
العلاقات ما بين القوى السياسيه في لبنان
ومحاوله الجميع
استغلالها لتحقيق مارب في قويه همم تخصهم
ولذلك يعود مره اخرى الى طرح قضيه الاخوه
الانسانيه
نعم
لذلك اعود مره اخرى الى اهميه طرح قضيه
الاخوه الانسانيه ان ان الاخوه الانسانيه
تساعد في لبنان وفي اي مجتمع على على في
الدنيا على تخفيف ان لم يكن على الغاء
التعصب على الغاء التطرف على الغاء على
فكره قبول
الاستغلال السياسي
للمشاعر همم الدينيه طبعا اذا
توافرت القناعه وهذا ما ما ما نراه لدى
المرجعيه الدينيه الكبرى في لبنان سواء
منها المسلمه والمسيحيه باهميه همم تبني
قضيه الاخوه الانسانيه ان عملا من هذا
النوع ان مبادره كبيره من هذا النوع اذا
تم الاقتناع بها على مستوى القيادات
الدينيه الكبرى اعني دار الفتوى
دار الفتوى المجلس الاسلامي الشيعي الاعلى
الشيخ عقل طائفه الموحدين الدروس وشيخ همم
الشيخ همم العلويين الى جانب هذا في
الجانب الاسلامي في الجانب المسيحي طبعا
غبطه البطريرك الراعي والمطر الكيات
المسيحيه جميعها اذا توافرت لي همم
القناعه ذاتها
لدى كل هذه المرجعيات انا اؤمن اننا
انه يمكن
ان تكون بدايه الطريق نحو تغيير الواقع
روما روما معك الاستاذ طلال خريص قبل قبل
دقائق كان يتحدث الدكتور عبد الباسط سلامه
هيكل من القاهره تحدث عن
التشكيك في الدين الاسلامي والطعن في نبي
الاسلام والى غيرها من الافكار الموجوده
في اوروبا عندما يذهب البابا
فرنسيس الى الى بلد اسلامي ويبين بذلك ان
ان الحوار مع العالم الاسلامي ممكن هل
يوجد هل نشاط برنامج تحرك للحبر الاعظم
هنا في اوروبا مثلا حيث
يتنامى الشعور المعادي للاسلام والمسلمين
وهذا ايضا خطر همم
يهدد الاخوه الانسانيه
استاذ علاء الخير روما
طبعا طبعا الوضع يختلف تماما اليوم حتى ان
الاحزاب اليمنيه التي تطرح قبل يعني
وصولها الى السلطه اننا علينا ان نبعد
النازحين وغير ذلك عندما تاتي الى السلطه
يعني انا اريد ان اعطي مثالا على ذلك انا
قلت انني مراسل وانقل دائما ما اراه في
عام
190 2001 جاء اليمين الى السلطه
واكرم همم
سن قانون هو من افضل القوانين حيث سوى همم
وضع اكثر من 500,000 مواطن كانوا خارجين
عن القانون ومعظمهم من المسلمين يعني
عندما تكون بالسلطه هناك موقف وعندما تكون
في المعارضه هناك موقف استهلاك يعني
بايطاليا اليوم حتى زعيمه الحزب اليمني
التي وصلت الى السلطه اليوم هي تبنت كل
القرارات وكل القوانين التي سنه قبلها وهي
قناه قوانين عادله يعني لم لم تمنع السفن
من البحث والانقاذ في البحر الابيض
المتوسط بل قالت بانها هؤلاء النازحين يجب
توزيعهم بشكل عادي على اوروبا يعني هناك
مبالغه شديده ب- همم
بالتشكيك بهذا الموضوع يعني ليس هناك
اعتداءات على المسلمين هناك علاقه جيده
يعني الوضع يختلف تماما عما نراه في
الاعلام بصراحه يعني اليوم انا انا اسكن
في منطقه همم كل الناس تحبني وكل الناس تت
اسمها ايه والكنيسه بالفعل لها ادور كبير
يعني اليوم الكنيسه هي تبحث عن الفقراء لا
تنظر الى هذا الفقير اذا كان مسلم او
مسيحي فهي
تقوم بمساعدته بغض النظر عن شكلها او دين
او اي شيء انا اعتقد لان الامور ليست بهذا
الحجم الذي نرى وهنا التسامح في بعض الدول
مثل المجر يعني اليمين همم يتمادى فيها
كثيرا همم في فرنسا ايضا ولكن الوضع
بايطاليا ووضع عايش مشترك وتسامح
والايطالي هو ايضا مغترب يعني هناك اكثر
من 100 مليون ايطالي يعيشون في الاغتراب
هم تشرد وذهبوا على
ظهر البواخر كما حدث بالنسبه
للمغاربه يعني المواطن الايطالي
ويشعر مع المواطن الاجنبي بلاغ انا لا ارى
لان هناك معامل سيئه للمغتربين في ايطاليا
او الناجحين
من روما شكرا لك شكرا دكتور عبد الباسط
السلامه هيكل من القاهره وشكرا للدكتور
سليم الطاهر من
بيروت شكرا كذلك الاستاذ عبد الله الجنيد
كان معنا من المنامه ولاسباب انتقاليه
تعذر عليه البقاء معنا في هذا النقاش الذي
انتهى الان شكرا على المتابعه مشاهدينا
الاعزاء الى اللقاء شكرا